I've got something you're gonna like in  particular you missed this very painful  this story there was a giant fire people  may recall at a Jim Beam Factory in  Kentucky about six million bottles the  equivalent of bourbon ran into the  Kentucky River there are some images of  the fire uh you ever heard the phrase  drinks like a fish  yes apparently not because the river is  turning up thousands of dead fish as a  plume of bourbon a plume of bourbon 20  miles long making its way down the river  environmental authorities are in the  river with barges there aerating the  water to up the oxygen levels and  hopefully save some fish to date they  have not made a special request any  bourbon drinkers with long straws to get  in and suck up the six million bottles  I'd be down there you can catch a flight  maybe not very saddened for the fish but  honestly even sadder that we lost all  that but he thought about you last week  we talked about anything you would not  like that